okay so in this presentation we're going
to go over genetic pedigrees how to read
them how to analyze them how to
construct them so let's go ahead and get
started so my goal is by the end if I
were to give you a pedigree like this
you would be able to identify the
individual genotypes every circular
square represents a person and again we
all have genotypes gene combinations and
so I'm hoping by the end you can solve
this pedigree right here let's go ahead
and get started so when we look at a
genetic pedigree they're very similar to
family trees because they show
relationships you know in this picture
here we have a man a man and a woman and
I have a branch connecting them to a
young lady that was that's their child
and as the years go by she meets this
gentleman right here maybe they both
enjoy gardening together and a
relationship between them starts and
they end up having two children and so
genetic pedigrees are very much like
family trees you know very common
activity you probably did in elementary
school was build a family tree it was a
way for you to get to know some of your
family members a little bit better well
a genetic pedigree is very much like a
family tree because they show
relationships but more importantly we
look at pedigrees because it allows us
to track a gene or it allows us to track
a trait throughout a family if a family
has a history of a trait such as such
such as sickle cell disease or cystic
fibrosis we can track that person or we
can track that gene from person to
person to person throughout the family
which can be really helpful when when
young men and young women are deciding
whether or not they want to raise a
family they can figure out the odds that
their child might have a disorder
so here we have an example of the
pedigree it's that same pedigree we saw
now notice how there are various symbols
the circles and any time you see a
pedigree the circles represent women and
the squares represent men now notice how
some of the circles and squares are
shaded in in this case they're shaded
blue what that means whenever you see a
pedigree that's shaded that means that
that person has a trait again usually
that's going to mean they have a gene
disorder a genetic disorder
so perhaps person 110 and 12 have the
disorder of you know sickle-cell disease
but that's generally what these symbols
mean so if you were to examine this
pedigree and I were to ask you in which
individuals are males pause the answer
I'm going to show it in 3 or pause the
video I'm going to show it in 3 2 1
so I hope you found individual 2 3 5 7
10 11 and 13 are all males because
they're squares
well here's another question which
individuals are female pause the video
I'm going to go over the answers in
three two one
so I hope all you had to do is identify
the circles circle one four six eight
nine and twelve are females and this
question right here which individuals in
this family have a genetic disorder I'm
going to go over the answer so pause the
video I'm going to show the answers in
three two one I hope you chose these
three people person one ten and twelve
these three people have a genetic
disorder well we're going to go over
some examples today so why don't we get
started with our first example so we're
going to examine a fictional family
using a disease known as PKU as the
example in this particular family in the
picture you can see that a blood test is
being done on an infant PKU is a disease
that stands for phenylketonuria and what
we do is when when a when a newborn baby
is born we'll take a blood sample and
based on how bacteria react to that
blood sample we can determine if a
person has PKU okay so let's go ahead
and meet this fictional family so here
we have a man and a woman and I want to
I want to go over the pattern for this
particular video we're going to focus on
PKU which is a disease that is autosomal
recessive when a man and a woman have a
child there is there are four possible
gene combinations that's why whenever
you do a Punnett square there's four
punnett squares to fill in because
there's four different ways that these
genes can combine that's why we have
this man and a woman and then four
babies so the first possibility the baby
might inherit a capital dominant H from
the father a capital dominant H from the
mother this individual would be
homozygous dominant they'd be healthy
the next possible combination would be
this right here the might they might
inherit a capital H from the father and
a lowercase H from the mother this
combination is called heterozygous this
person would also be healthy but they
would be what's called a carrier a third
possible combination they might inherit
a lowercase H and a capital a lowercase
H from the father and a capital H from
the mother this too is also called
heterozygous it doesn't matter if you
put the capital or the lowercase letter
first but it's a good habit to put the
capital letter first so I'm going to do
that right now and so the last
combination that a child might in here
might be a lower H from each parent this
would be called homozygous recessive and
when you look at these four possible
outcomes right here these are called
genotypes you can see that only one out
of the four there's only a one in four
chance that this mom and dad could have
a child with the disease PKU those other
three children those other three gene
combinations are all healthy so let's go
ahead and meet our fictional family okay
so here we go we're going to actually
create a pedigree here based on some
information about a fictional family and
like the last example we're going to
pretend that this family has a history
of a disease called PKU and so Manny and
Rosa a man and woman let's keep this
family friendly and they're both married
and they're both healthy so notice how I
drew a square for Manny because Manny
implies a male's name and a circle for
Rosa because Rosa implies a woman's name
and so I connected the circle in the
square that implies that they're
together and so this is what we
typically see of a married man and woman
you don't have to be married of course
to have a child but let's keep this
family friendly so second step pretend
that they have three children over the
years what I'm going to do is I'm going
to draw three branches coming down from
Manny and Rosa at the end of each branch
will soon be a child
says their oldest child Jacob has a
recessive disorder called PKU so first
of all you generally put the oldest
child on the left so I have a square
there for Jacob because Jacob implies a
boy's name but the the statement also
tells me that Jacob has a recessive
disorder called PKU he has the disease
so that's why I'm going to color in
Jacob square typically when you see
someone colored in that means they have
the disorder they have the gene moving
on their middle child Erica and the
youngest child Matthew are both healthy
so Erica implies a circle for a girl and
again you typically put the oldest on
the left and therefore the youngest on
the right so Matthew is implies a boy's
name and so I have a square there well
let's go ahead and pause and let's go
ahead and stop and try to figure out
what are the genotypes of these five
people so far
I know Jacob has to be homozygous
recessive to lowercase H's because
that's the only combination possible of
having the disease PKU the other four
people are healthy so there's a problem
there the other four people are healthy
and there's two possible gene
combinations there's two possible
genotypes that lead to healthy I got to
figure out which genotypes are they
so first of all when I want to figure
out what Gina what genotype they are
let's start with Manny and Rosa mom and
dad I know Jacob has the disease well we
get our DNA we inherit our traits from
mom and dad
so Jacob has two lowercase H's one of
those had to come from each parent the
story never tells me Manny and Rosa were
heterozygous but because Jacob has the
disease he has to be heterozygous I can
cross out homozygous dominant
so now that I know Manny and Rosa
why don't I build a punnett square let
me build a punnett square in the upper
right hand corner for Manny and Rosa
there's the genotype for Manny there's a
genotype for Rosa and now I just fill in
the punnett square the top left square
the top right square the lower left
square the lower right square and when I
do I can see Erika and Mathieu clearly
are not the square in the bottom right
hand corner they're not homozygous
recessive because they would have the
disease I know they're healthy so right
now I'm kind of stuck with Erica and
Matthew I don't know their exact
genotype they're either capital H
capital H there's a one out of three
chance of that or their capital H
lowercase H there's a two out of three
chance of that but I don't know for sure
let's move on
moving on with our little fictional
family here Erica goes away to college
and while at college she meets healthy
healthy gentleman by the name of Moe and
the two become married so when there we
go we just inserted Moe and we connected
him to Erica implying that they're
together
Erica and Moe end up having two
daughters so I'm going to make a branch
with two ends and daughters implies I'm
going to draw circles two circles for
women their youngest daughter Jamie
tests positive for the disease PKU but
Amy does not so again the youngest is on
the right the oldest is on the left so
I'm going to color in the circle on the
right for Jamie and I'm going to leave
the circle on the left blank for Amy
just like last time let's go ahead and
record the genotypes of Erica Moe Amy
and Jamie so let's go ahead and look at
Jamie Jamie has to be homozygous
recessive she has two lowercase H's it's
the only way she can have the disease
that's the only possible combination
well where did she get those two
lowercase H is from okay before we
address Jamie and how she got those two
lowercase H's I know Moe is healthy
there's two possible combinations for
healthy and I know Amy's healthy the
story tells me Amy's house healthy so
there's two possible combinations for
Amy
well now let's turn our attention back
to Jamie Jamie is a big clue here Jamie
has the disease she's got two lowercase
H's well where did those come from we
get our DNA from mom and dad one of
those lower H's had to come from mom one
of those lower ages had to come from dad
I now know that Moe has to be
heterozygous and I now have missing
information about Erica I used to not
know Erica erica used to have a question
mark but because Jamie was born we now
have more information that give
that sheds light on to the under the
question of what is Erica's genotype she
has to be heterozygous
Moe's heterozygous again for that same
reason so let's go ahead like last time
let's do a Punnett square in the upper
right hand corner and there's the
letters for Erica on the outside of the
punnett square
there's the letters for moe and like
last time we just fill in the top left
fill in the top right fill in the bottom
left fill in the bottom right and when
we look at our finish to punnett square
I know amy is not the square in the
lower right hand corner she's not
homozygous recessive because I know this
story tells me she's healthy you see my
problem just like Matthew in the diagram
I don't know Amy's genotype there's a
one out of three chance that she's
homozygous dominant capital H capital H
there's a two out of three chance that
she's home was I excuse me two out of
three chance that she's heterozygous
capital H lowercase H all I know she's
healthy so there you go there's a very
quick and simple pedigree analyzing a
fictional family I want to give you
another practice
so now that we just got done with that
example there's going to be another
family on the next slide this family
pretend has a history of sickle-cell
disease just like PKU it's autosomal
recessive you have to inherit two
lowercase H's so here we go so here we
have a bunch of people in this family
pause the video pause the video and try
to figure out the genotypes of everybody
notice the hint in the upper left hand
corner you will not be able to solve
three people in this family I'm not
going to tell you who until the end
pause the video I'm going to start going
over the answers in three two one so to
get started start with the four symbols
that are shaded in they have to be
lowercase H lowercase H homozygous
recessive because that means they have
the disease
so already four people out of this
family are finished let's move on
next everybody else everyone who's not
colored in I know they're healthy
they're healthy because they're not
colored in so I'm going to go ahead and
give everybody else one capital H
because I know they're healthy maybe
they have another capital H maybe not
but I know they have at least one okay
let's focus on George George has to be
heterozygous how do we know that there's
actually two clues two ways we can
figure out George
clue number one if George was capital H
capital H if George was homozygous
dominant he would give every one of his
children a capital H he would give Tom
Sam Wilma and Anna capital H and
therefore none of the kids would have
the disease another way we know George
is heterozygous is look at two of his
children Tom and Wilma are his children
they each have the disease and they each
have two lowercase H's one had to come
from mom Arlene the other had to come
from dad George
all right now I want you to focus on Sam
and n salmon and must be heterozygous
how do we know that well here's the
answer our lane their mother is the clue
our lien has two lowercase H's that
means whoever whoever is born from
Arlene whoever is Arlene's child is
going to get a lowercase H from her
she's got four children Tom Sam Wilma
and Ann the next person I want you to
focus on is Michael Michael has to be
heterozygous capital H lowercase H how
do we know that well we know that
because of his daughter his daughter
Carla is the clue she has the disease so
she must have inherited one lowercase H
from his/her mother and and the other
lowercase H from her father Michael
okay now I want you to focus on Daniel
and Alan Daniel and Alan also must be
heterozygous capital H lowercase H how
do we know this the clue is their father
their father Tom is the clue Tom has two
lowercase H's he's going to pass on a
lowercase H to any of his children he
happens to have two children only named
Daniel and Alan so tom is going to give
a lowercase H to all of his children
and so now there's only three people
left my hint was that three people are
going to be unknown and so that's why I
added question marks - Sondra Tina and
Christopher how do we know that they're
unknown because all we know is that
they're healthy we don't know what
combination of healthy they are
homozygous dominant capital H capital H
or homozygous recessive capital H
lowercase H so there you go I hope that
was a good a good a good review or a
good explanation for how to build a
pedigree if you want pause the video and
I was one of the goals at the beginning
was that you would be able to solve
these thirteen people pause the video
and try to and try to finish these if
you're in my biology class I'd be happy
to check your answers for accuracy bring
them to me before school or after school
and I'd be happy to check good luck